top diplomats and high-ranking military
officials from Turkey have agreed to
coordinate with Russia on the Syria
crisis after holding talks in Moscow
which finished up in the last hour or so
it comes after the situation in Syria
escalated following Donald Trump's
surprise decision to pull US troops out
of the country but let's get more on the
talks now our correspondent - oceans
across what's been happening hi there so
what's been announced by Turkey and
Russia
I have to say that despite the meeting
taking place in snow in Moscow that is
now totalling to New Year holiday season
you can see Christmas tree behind me I
have to say that very serious topics on
the agenda serious fate and Russia and
Turkey coordinated work on the ground
now after us announced its troops
withdrew it is expected to take up to
100 days but certainly it is changing
the situation in Syria already now
especially in the region east of the
Euphrates River this is where the
American military have been present and
once they are out this territory that is
now officially under the control of the
Kurdish forces may become especially
vulnerable so the Russian and Turkish
delegations that included top diplomats
defense ministers and intelligence
Chiefs met here in Moscow to discuss
what should be done to avoid any
military confrontation in this area
between any forces and there are many
fractions on the ground as you know this
is what Syrian conflict has been
especially sadly famous for and that's
especially after turkey saying it is
getting ready for an assault against
Kurds in series North courage that
Ankara sees as terrorists so Russia and
Turkey met to see what should be done
what they could do to avoid a military
confrontation which means death people
what should be done to boost return of
refugees a to Syria and displaced people
back to their homes and what to do to
bring peace to
serious solutions speaking to media
following the meeting russia's Foreign
Minister Sergei Lavrov has specifically
mentioned the Syrian constitutional
committee let's take a listen on the
story she thought sir during the talks
we specifically mentioned that Russia
and Turkey with the participation of our
Iranian colleagues did everything
promised to create a Syrian
constitutional committee this has been
done by our states as mediators between
the Syrian government and opposition and
we hope that those including our Western
partners who called the Astana group to
finish his work as soon as possible
would not interfere in his continued
work Russia and Turkey I rather
optimistic on how things developer in
Syria right now and also added that they
believe in hope that the new year will
bring more positive changes to this
war-torn country and may be a
long-awaited peace will finally come
them back to you okay thanks for that
update maria fernanda outside the
russian foreign ministry in central
Moscow now the northern part of Syria
has been a battleground on several
occasions since the war started back in
2011 and he spent the Bakr Duch
population there haven't seen peace for
a long time he goes to Don off takes a
closer look at their role in all of this
they call themselves freedom fighters
turkey calls them terrorists the u.s.
used them as their proxy army well after
this used to there will be a strong
deliberate and orderly withdrawal of US
forces from Syria very deliberate very
orderly turkey has already begun massing
its forces on the front line and the
Kurds
all too well the consequences of that
they've been there with Afrin back in
January the Turks launched Operation
Olive Branch against the minorities
northernmost territories there were
reports the Syrian army could have
intervened but in the end the Kurds put
on a brave face and decided to go it
alone and Efrain fell and quickly for
the Turkish army the operation was
hardly more challenging than a drill
[Music]
the Turks almost moved deeper to another
major Kurdish stronghold of manwich
their us generals literally had to put
their bodies between the two to prevent
bloodshed now the US is abandoning Syria
and the Kurds while Aragon has been
making it clear that a Kurdish held
manwich just won't stand with them these
terrorists have to go to the east of
Euphrates if they do not leave we will
send them that was postponed eventually
but not indefinitely unless the Kurds
leave manwich Julian we are already
against serious division our entire aim
is to make terrorist organizations leave
the area if the terrorists leave then
there is no work left for us anyway the
American withdrawal has left the Kurds
with a limited number of options really
so they've turned to Damascus asking to
shield them we invite the Syrian
government which we belong to to send
its armed forces to take over these
positions and protect mine Beach in the
face of Turkish threats in response to
the requests of the population of manbij
the Syrian government and its Armed
Forces announced it is sending in troops
to manbij and so there they are the
government forces have entered the
Kurdish Kingdom for the first time in
years with Russia being a major
influence on Damascus Turkey is once
again turning to Moscow so the cards
have been dealt
and now it's down to Turkey if they will
go all in
you